[Music]
in 2018 i got married and i left the
previous job
later i blessed with a beautiful son but
still i wanted to prove myself having my
own identity so i choose to work as a
career break is one of the major hurdles
to getting a job nowadays so i just
found simply learn as one of the best
organization so i just joined the course
the course i took was
full stack java developer this is a
course which contains backend
front-end and database also
i'm bharathi from tamil nadu
i was currently working in a cab germany
as a senior analyst
nurturing a baby is itself a full-time
job for a mother but still i wanted
myself
my own identity
other than a mother other than wife
other than a daughter so i just wanted
myself to upskill me
in that
point i chose simply law the best thing
in the course i liked was
the recording session the recording was
very useful
so that you can watch the recording
whenever you have free time and also you
can go through with that the mentors who
taught me us given their personal ids
and linkedin profiles they shared and we
can we are very open to ask the doubts
with them
the mentor name nisha weiker
she taught me the java basics and as i
am new for java coding everything she is
the one who opened my eyes for java
she thought each and everything from the
scratch and she cleared all the doubts
for each and every
learners
we all find actually very useful
because
learning a new thing is not that much
easier the basics should be strong
enough
she gave me the strong basics in java
i'm just happy to get this new job after
taking a career break
and having a baby i was still able to
upskill myself and land into this new
job